we are proud to present today author
of when the mississippi ran backwards
empire intrigue murder and the new
madrid earthquakes
mr j feldman mr feldman holds an m.a in
dramatic arts from the university of
california at berkeley
his articles have appeared in many
publications
including smithsonian newsweek sports
illustrated
the new york times gourmet and the whole
earth review
a number of his pieces have been
anthologized
he has written for television film and
stage
and is the author of hitting an official
major league baseball book
when the mississippi runs ran backwards
tells the story of the development of
transportation and settlement
along the river the efforts of the
native population especially tecumseh
to resist that settlement the war of
1812 on the frontier
and even the horrific murder of a slave
when i read this book i was astounded to
learn about the length of time that the
new madrid fault
shook and the number of major quakes and
aftershocks
howard zinn author of a people's history
of the united states
says of when the mississippi ran
backwards
that jay feldman has produced a
fascinating work of social history
meticulously researched elegantly
written
and awesomely original in its conception
he finds the convulsions of the natural
world
reverberating on slavery war and indian
resistance
and tells the story of with verve
and style the missouri history society
and left bank books are privileged to
present the author of
when the mississippi ran backwards
empire intrigue
murder and the new madrid earthquakes mr
j
feldman
[Applause]
thank you jan thank you all for coming
out on a beautiful spring
afternoon and thank you to the missouri
historical society for
for hosting my talk today
when the mississippi ran backwards is
the story of the largest series of
earthquakes ever to hit the united
states
it's also a social and political history
of the early frontier
when we hear the term frontier our minds
tend to jump
to the kansas nebraska dakotas
part of the country and the years
1860 1870
this frontier was
50 years earlier and
500 to 750 miles east
the term frontier is a very fluid
concept
it was constantly changing and
constantly moving
one of the chief characteristics of the
frontier is that no
one group could claim sovereignty
so that the frontier that we're talking
about here involved power struggle
between
and among great britain
france spain the united states and of
course all the native american tribes of
the region
everything was up for grabs everything
was fluid
and it was a wild and wooly place
when the mississippi ran backwards
weaves together five
story lines to create a complex
tapestry and mural
of these times
the first story involves the settling
and establishment of new madrid
until 1800
spain belonged spain owned the louisiana
territory
how did spain get the louisiana
territory
in 1763 at the end of the french and
indian war
to avoid having to cede the louisiana
territory to the british that's how the
british got canada the end of the french
and indian war
to avoid having to cede louisiana
territory
to the british the french king gave the
louisiana territory
to his cousin the spanish king
and until 1800 when napoleon grabbed it
back
louisiana belonged to spain
in 1790 george morgan a patriot of the
american revolution
set out to establish a colony
in spanish louisiana and the place he
chose was new madrid
because of its strategic location on the
river
so the first part of this story involves
the establishment of new madrid by
george morgan and the
intrigue that went on around the
establishment of new madrid
including a fascinating character named
james wilkinson
one of the boldest scoundrels in early
american history
the second story involves tecumseh's
prophecy
the great shawnee chief tecumseh had set
out
to establish a pan-tribal confederacy
and he recruited among the northern
tribes
in what we now call the old northwest
territory
which was the area around ohio michigan
wisconsin that whole
area throughout the ohio
valley and then turn
southward to the southern tribes the
purpose of this confederation
was to resist the advance of the federal
government's
acquisition of native american lands
as settlers poured over the allegheny
mountains
and then later with a louisiana purchase
across the mississippi river
1803 remember the louisiana purchase
conflicts with the native american
tribes became inevitable
and the acquisition of indian lands
was moving ahead at an alarming rate
for the tribes
this was not the first attempt at a
pan-tribal confederacy
earlier on leaders like pontiac
the ottawa the great mohawk chief joseph
brandt and the creek leader alexander
mcgillivray
all tried to establish
a confederacy involving many tribes
tecumseh's was the most effective in no
small part because of
the force and
magnetism the charisma of his
personality
on a southern recruiting trip to the
chickasaw choctaw
cherokee and creek nations in the fall
of 1811
at one particular meeting in
a creek village named takabachi
he gave his recruitment talk but this
one particular
creek chief that he was eager to enlist
was resistant
finally tecumseh said look i understand
i know why
you're not joining up is not a direct
quote
he said you don't think that i've been
sent here by the great spirit
but i'll tell you what when i leave here
i go to detroit and when i reach detroit
i'm going to stamp my foot and knock
down every house in takabachi
while the creek started counting the
days
in fact when the first earthquake hit
tecumseh was nowhere near detroit
but the creeks calculating
that it would be about the time that he
would be
arriving in detroit or stunned
when the first of the new magic
earthquakes was unleashed on december 16
1811
and it set them on the road to war
the effects of which were devastating
for the creek nation
the creek war of 1813 and 14
which was the southern front of the war
of 1812.
we tend to forget that the war of 1812
was every bit as much a war against the
native americans as it was against the
british
in many in many uh cases the british and
the
native american tribes were allied
so there were actually three fronts in
the war of 1812 there was the niagara
front
there was the front in upper canada
centered around detroit where tecumseh
fought with the british
and then there was the creek war down
south
by the end of the war of 1812 which was
the last battle you recall was january
8th
1815 the battle of new orleans
the entire country
throughout the mississippi valley and
ohio valleys
and southeast with the one exception
of the seminoles who carried on until
the eighteen fifties
but the ohio valley the mississippi
valley
and the southeastern part of the country
indian resistance was crushed
moreover the british and french no
longer had a claim
on the united states
and when the spanish were driven from
florida five years later
the entire land from the eastern
seaboard
on the east to the end of the louisiana
purchase on the
on the west from the canadian border
to the mexican border and the gulf of
mexico
was u.s land many contemporaries
referred to the war of 1812 as the
second american revolution
i think a better way of putting it would
be it was the war that consolidated the
american revolution because this
territory was now
the united states the third story
involves an unspeakably
horrible and brutal murder by
two nephews of thomas jefferson
isham and lilburn lewis had moved to
western kentucky from virginia
and they were living in the southwestern
most
corner of kentucky as it was constituted
at that time
they murdered one of their slaves on the
very eve of the earthquake
december 15 1811.
two o'clock in the morning
on december 16th the first quake hit
the murder was brought to light by the
earthquakes
the fourth story is the story of the
steamboat new orleans
the very first steamboat on the ohio and
mississippi rivers
if you recall robert fulton's claremont
had successfully negotiated the trip
from new york city to albany just three
years earlier
and nicholas and lydia roosevelt the
great grand uncle and great grand aunt
of theodore roosevelt
set out to prove that the western rivers
were capable of steamboat travel
there was some skepticism about this and
for good reasons
unlike the hudson river where fulton's
claremont
made its historic voyage the ohio and
mississippi
especially the mississippi were rather
more wild
and untamed rivers the currents and the
hazards
were extremely great
and nobody believed
that a steamboat could make it
down much less up river
on the mississippi
lydia roosevelt was a remarkable woman
a year before the steamboat voyage they
had undertaken a flat boat voyage
to gauge the rivers
the voyage began when she was
several months pregnant and
by the time the flat boat reached new
orleans
she was eight months pregnant
when they returned to new york by
sailing ship she gave birth to her first
child a daughter when the new orleans
left pittsburgh in october 1811
lydia roosevelt was eight months
pregnant
and gave birth to her second child a son
on the steamboat
while it was docked in louisville
waiting for the falls
to rise so they could overcome that
hazard
the steamboat new orleans the maiden
voyage
of any steamboat on
the ohio and mississippi rivers
was caught in the earthquakes
the first earthquake hit just as the
boat was near cairo what's now
cairo
the steamboat survived that disaster
quite admirably unlike most of the other
boats on the river which were
swamped and tossed about like toys in a
bathtub
and proved conclusively that
steamboats were suited for
the western rivers
the fifth story of course is the story
of the new madrid earthquakes
the new madrid earthquakes went on for
four months
there were approximately two thousand
separate events
tremors the three largest
on december 16th january
23rd 1812 and february 7
1812 would have measured
up around 8.0 give or take on the later
devised
richter scales
devastating damage in the whole region
church bells rang in boston
china clattered in new york
the quakes were felt in canada they were
felt in new orleans they were felt in
charleston south carolina and just about
every place up and down
the eastern seaboard
my research for this book took me to
many places
i went to spain because many of
the documents
pertaining to the establishment of new
madrid are still
in spanish libraries
i conducted research at the biblioteca
nacional
in madrid and the archivo de indias
in sevilla i also went to
the national archives and the library of
congress in washington dc
i took a barge trip
down the ohio river to get the real
feeling of what it was like to be out on
the river
i went to the center for earthquake
research and information
in memphis tennessee and spoke to
several seismologists and geologists
whose
careers have been largely devoted to
studying the new madrid earthquakes
and i drove up and down the mississippi
valley and ohio valleys between
louisville and memphis on both banks
was a fellow in blythe arkansas
who took me all over the area to show me
the evidence
the surface evidence that still exists
of those quakes and he even dug up his
backyard with his backhoe
so i could see the strata and the
evidence
of the quakes that's buried
everything else i was able to get from
interlibrary loan at the university of
california in davis
which is my hometown
i was keeping them in business for two
years
i have no doubt that when they saw me
coming they wanted a duck behind the
counter on many occasions but they were
unfailingly gracious
and fulfilled virtually every request i
made
i want to read a short passage from the
book
and then i want to talk a little bit
about the making of the book
and i want to talk about why there are
earthquakes
in the mississippi valley and of course
including
the meaning of the title of the book
in august 1910 a landmark council was
held in the town of vincennes
fort knox in indiana territory
the conference included a number of
territorial officials and a dozen chiefs
of the northwest tribes
and it brought together for the first
time the two men
who had become the principal adversaries
in the u.s indian struggle for control
of the frontier
shawnee chief tecumseh and indiana
territory governor william henry
harrison
the meetings were held at a fenced-off
grassy area in a grove
near the governor's home as agreed upon
beforehand tecumseh left behind most of
the 75 warriors who had accompanied him
to vincennes
arriving at the clearing with an escort
of only a dozen chiefs
also by agreement tecumseh and his party
left their firearms
at their camp bringing only tomahawks
and war clubs to the council
arriving at the meeting ground they
found the governor seated on a platform
with several other indiana officials
nearby a small guard of a dozen soldiers
from fort knox stood nervously by
also present were several pro-government
chiefs
including harrison's potawatomi
sycophant winamek
whom tecumseh had already threatened to
kill for his part in the signing of the
treaty of fort wayne
which had transferred three million
acres of tribal lands in indiana
to the united states a year earlier
harrison sat stiffly in his chair
awaiting the arrival of his opponent
he had prepared a chair for tecumseh
next to his own on the platform
when the shawnee chief entered the
council area harrison beckoned him to
come and take the seat that had been
reserved for him
your father invites you to be seated
said the governor in a patronizing tone
gesturing toward the empty chair
solemnly and defiantly to come
disappointed at the sky
he paused for emphasis and said governor
harrison is not my father
the great spirit is my father he pointed
at the ground
saying the earth is my mother and i will
repose upon her bosom
then he sat on the grass
following tecumseh's lead the rest of
his party took their seats on the ground
the effect wrote one chronicler of the
council was electrical
and for some moments there was a perfect
silence
the meeting had gotten off on a note of
friction and the tension would build
steadily over the next few days
at 37 harrison was five years younger
than tecumseh
the governor who had many years of
experiencing intimate and intimidating
defeated and accommodationist chiefs
was taken aback by the shawnee's
boldness
it was he after all not this savage who
was in charge
harrison was a hardliner when it came to
acquiring indian lands for the federal
government
few men could match the ruthless and
heartless zeal of william henry harrison
between 1802 and 1805 alone
employing trickery bribery cajolery
threats
and whiskey the governor had signed
seven treaties with various tribes
giving the united states title to vast
areas of present-day indiana missouri
wisconsin and illinois
the tribes were compensated at the rate
of two cents an acre
harrison began by telling tecumseh he
understood that the chief had issues to
raise
and promised to listen fairly
but diplomacy was not harrison's long
suit
he insisted that he had always treated
the indians honorably and justly
and that tecumseh was the first person
to accuse him
of acting otherwise harrison also stated
that he had heard reports blaming
tecumseh
for stirring up trouble between the
northwestern tribes
and the united states by claiming that
the chiefs who sold the lands in the
fort wayne treaty
had no right to do so he challenged the
shawnee to declare
under a clear sky and in an open path
whether these reports were true
tecumseh rose slowly to his feet
in his compelling style the chief began
by putting forth the position
that tribal lands were held in common
and declared that the treaties had been
negotiated deceitfully and therefore
null and void he spoke scornfully of the
indians who sat near harrison heaping
abuse on winamek
and promising the accommodationist
chiefs that they would be punished for
their betrayal
which so unnerved the potawatomi that he
began loading the pearl-handled pistol
he had received as a gift from harrison
finally tecumseh acknowledged that he
had organized a confederation
to resist further encroachments by the
government but insisted he did not want
war
if the government would return the land
of the fort wayne treaty
there would be no hostilities john
badalet
of the vincennes land office an
outspoken critic of harrison's
wrote his friend albert gallatin the
secretary of the treasury
that tecumseh spoke to the governor with
a freedom and sense which excited
surprise
he reproached him in the face of day
with having bought the land from tribes
which had no right to it
or from persons whom he himself had made
chiefs
it is my opinion that government ought
to look closer into this business
and rather to cherish than exasperate
that man
that the indians want nothing but good
treatment to become well disposed
to the united states that day and the
next
as had come to be expected of him
tecumseh delivered a series of long
powerful speeches
in which he chronicled the past
injustices of the united states
government
towards native americans the litany of
wrongs
went back decades and covered a great
deal of ground
there are unfortunately too many of them
wrote harrison to secretary of war
william eustis
in his account of the proceedings
harrison's answers to tecumseh's charge
were vague and evasive
he was offended by tecumseh's lack of
deference
later writing to eustace that while
tecumseh was obviously the great man of
the party
his speeches the first two days were
sufficiently insolent
and his pretensions arrogant
after several days frustrated by the
sense that he was getting nowhere with
harrison
to come to look the governor in the eye
and told him earnestly
brother i wish you to listen to me well
as i think you do not clearly understand
what i before said to you i shall
explain it again
he once again enumerated a lengthy list
of atrocities committed by the whites
against native americans
including the 1782 massacre of 96
peaceful christian delaware's at the
moravian mission
at not in hooton by u.s soldiers
how to come suppressed harrison after
this conduct
can you blame me for placing little
confidence in the promises of our
fathers the americans
how can we have confidence in the white
people when jesus christ came upon the
earth
you killed him and nailed him on a cross
tecumseh concluded his talk with a
typical flourish
brother since the peace was made you
have killed some of the
shawnees winnebagos delawares and
miami's and you have taken our lands
from us
and i do not see how we can remain at
peace with you if you continue to do so
to come says plea fell on deaf ears
in answer to the chief's accusations
harrison denied that the government had
ever acted in bad faith
and asserted that the u.s had always
treated the indians fairly
he disputed tecumseh's contention that
the tribes were one nation
citing as evidence the fact that the
great spirit had given them many
different tongues
he chastises chastise the shawnee leader
telling him that the fort wayne treaty
lands had been purchased from the miami
tribe
and that tecumseh had no right to come
from a foreign land and tell the miamis
what they could
and could not do with their own lands
the speech was first translated into
shawnee
then as the interpreter began to explain
harrison's double talk to the
potawatomi's
tecumseh lost his temper and leap to his
feet
using emphatic and uncharacteristically
violent gestures
he interrupted the translator and
angrily accused harrison of lying
the interpreter quickly turned to the
governor informed him that the shawnee
chief had called him a liar
harrison's face flushed with anger and
he jumped up out of his chair
immediately everyone else on the
platform followed suit
seeing this tecumseh's entourage sprang
to their feet
in a flash the thin facade of civility
that
had crumbled exposing the animosity
that lay just below the surface
territorial secretary john gibson who
understood shawnee
urgently told harrison those fellows
intend mischief you had better bring up
the guard
harrison signaled for the guard to move
in and winimek once again charged his
pistol and primed it for firing
tecumseh's men crouched prepared to do
battle as the soldiers stepped forward
bayonets at the ready the warriors
brandished their war clubs
the troops cocked their rifles
tecumseh raised his tomahawk harrison
drew his sword
for one interminable heart-stopping
minute
the threat of violence hung over the
council as
thick as the humid indiana summer heir
but everyone froze in place and no when
nobody made the first move
the governor lowered his sword and
ordered the soldiers to let down their
rifles
sheathing his weapon harrison declared
the council over
telling tecumseh that he would respond
to the chief's charges and writings
and that if if tecumseh ever again
wanted to speak to him
he should do it through an intermediary
tecumseh's party left the meeting ground
and returned to their camp
that night while harrison was assembling
three companies of militia to protect
the town
tecumseh was regretting his impetuous
words
the next morning he sent a message of
apology which was accepted
the council resumed later that day
at the final meeting tecumseh spoke
calmly and politely but firmly
still defiant he warned harrison not to
interfere
in intertribal affairs and stated i
am alone the acknowledged head of all
the indians
as he finished he made one last poignant
plea
brother they want to save that piece of
land
we do not wish you to take it it is
small enough for our purposes
i want the present boundary to continue
should you cross it
i assure you it will be productive of
bad consequences
after tecumseh chiefs from several of
the other tribes spoke
affirming what the shawnee had said and
acknowledging him as their leader
at the end of the meetings tecumseh
asked harrison to send his remarks to
the great chief
president james madison harrison agreed
but cautioned that there was little
chance madison would approve of them
hearing this tecumseh shook his head
sadly
well he said as the great chief
is to determine the matter i hope the
great spirit will put enough sense into
his head
to induce him to direct you to give up
this land
it is true he is so far off he will not
be injured by the war
he may still sit in his town and drink
his wine
whilst you and i have to fight it out
i often get asked
how did i get on to this subject
in california where i live earthquakes
are always a topic
of discussion and about eight years ago
a friend of mine and i were casually
talking about
earthquakes and in the course of our
chat he
asked me did you know that there was a
very large earthquake around
st louis sometime about 200 years ago
this was news to me
and so i just took a quick look into it
at that time
and i found out not only was there an
earthquake there was this
major series of massive earthquakes
that went on for four months
and they were called the new madrid
earthquakes
and i kind of filed the idea in the back
of my mind
for maybe the setting for a historical
novel
maybe connect it with lewis and clark
somehow
it was just a vague germ of an idea
well three years after that i had
finished
another historical novel revolving
around
uh baseball in a japanese-american
internment camp during
world war ii
and i turned my attention to a new
subject
and these earthquakes surfaced from the
back of my mental filing cabinet
i thought aha i'll look into that
it wasn't too long after i started
researching this subject
that i discovered i couldn't
possibly write this story as fiction
it was just simply too far-fetched
the confluence of forces and events the
coincidences
that came into play here
would have seemed like too much of a
stretch
to write as a novel
i didn't have to invent anything it was
all in the historical record
i just had to dig it out
so i decided to write a non-fiction book
two other things really appealed to me
about this story
i started to see the earthquakes as as a
symbol a metaphor if you will
for the turmoil and the upheaval on the
early frontier
that they came to represent for me
something much larger than
just seismological and geological events
they came to represent the chaos
that was occurring at that place and
time
in almost every aspect of frontier life
and i also saw i was struck
by how many parallels there are
in these stories to themes and issues
that are still with us
as americans
so i set out to write a proposal for
this book that's the way it works in the
non-fiction world you write
as opposed to fiction where you write
the novel
and your agent sends out the whole book
in non-fiction you write a proposal
and the better it is the more extensive
the more convincing the more compelling
the writing
the more likely you are to sell it and
the more money you're likely to get is
in advance
i spent about six months
on the proposal itself it was fairly
extensive
it was around 110 pages it was finished
in the
early summer of 2001
but the publishing industry shuts down
for the summer in new york
so my agent said
we'll send it out right after labor day
well right after labor day the world
trade center was attacked on september
11th
and for about three months publishers
weren't buying anything but books on
terrorism and islam
and political analyses and things like
that
so now we're approaching the holidays
and the publishing industry shuts down
for the holidays in new york and my
agent said well we'll send out after new
year
i was checking my account balance in my
checking account
he did send it out right after the first
of the year
and several houses were interested and
we decided to
sign with simon schuster we very much
liked the way they were approaching the
project
the book was two years in the writing
and another year in production and it
was released on march 10th
a little more than a month ago
as far as why there are earthquakes in
the mississippi valley
a study of the earth's crust reveals a
cyclical
process it's called
continental drift and i'm sure many of
you are familiar with it
over millions and millions of years the
continents drift together
and slam into one another and
form one or perhaps two super continents
huge bodies of land
over the course of millions of years
again
those can't supercontinents
break up into smaller continents
and then they come back together and
then they break up again
and nobody knows how many times this has
happened
the last breakup of the continents
produced the pres
predecessor of north america which
geologists refer to as laurentia
the shape of that continent was a little
different than the
continent we live on what is now the
gulf of mexico
extended up into what is now the
mississippi valley
so that the entire area
of louisiana much of southern alabama
a lot of east texas parts of arkansas
were all underwater
at some point another rift started
right at that at the apex of that
body of water the continent started to
break apart right there
as if the whole area
from what is now the mississippi valley
to the east coast
would have floated off and formed a new
continent
the earth's crust tore
magma molten lava came bubbling up from
below
spread out over the land
for some reason the rift did not
complete itself
but when the lava cooled
the crust of the earth sank under
much the same conditions that when you
take a cake out of the oven
under the wrong circumstances it can
fall
so now we have this huge failed rift
valley this sunken land
350 miles long 150 miles
50 to 100 miles wide
that exists as a scar
in the earth's crust
much much later when the great inland
sea
that covered in much of north america
began to drain
that was the path it took the path of
least resistance through this
huge rift valley
this became the mississippi river
the water brought down with it billions
and billions of
tons of soil and earth
and silt and filled in
those areas that are now east texas
louisiana
alabama
so we now have three miles of
silt this unconsolidated sediment
sitting on this bedrock
which still has this scar
which still present persists as a zone
of weakness
in the north american continent
unlike the area
areas where two tectonic plates come
together
california the west coast of the united
states all the way up to alaska
where tectonic plates are bumping and
grinding against each other constantly
and produce
a fairly high and frequent incidence of
large events in the
middle of the continent
the incidence and frequency of large
events tends to be
separated but when they happen they're
enormous
what causes these
under the atlantic ocean at the
mid-atlantic ridge
new crust is constantly being created
and as it's forced up to the surface
which is the floor of the ocean
it spreads out in both directions
as it spreads west it moves
the north american plate two or three
centimeters a year
well the movement of that creates
enormous
stress over time on
the fault zone that lies below the
mississippi valley
i don't i don't mean to alarm you all
here but it's still down there
paleo seismological studies indicate
that
there were a massive series
of quakes in
900 a.d and again in 1450 a.d
and then of course we know we have a
historical record about the 18
11 and 12 quakes so you could say that
every 350 to
500 years give or take
there is a major series of earthquakes
in the new madrid
seismic zone
the title of the book comes from
two particular incidents
on two different occasions during
the major
quake on
january on december
16th and the last of the three major
events on february 7th
a huge block of land was thrust up
i'm talking about a
piece of land thousands of square miles
this block of land went across the river
now it's like when you're in the bathtub
and you push the water towards the end
there's only one place when it can where
it can come that's back
to you so here you have the river
flowing
and this huge block of land blocking its
way
it flowed back upstream with the same
effect as a tsunami it's not a tsunami
because it's not an ocean phenomenon
and it's not created by the same
conditions that created tsunami but the
effect was the same
a 30-foot high wall of water ran
retrograde spreading out over the banks
flooding acres and acres and miles
on both sides of the mississippi river
and carrying both swamping many boats
carrying them upstream
even during the second incident carrying
them so far
up onto the land that when the waters
receded the boats were left high and dry
there's even a description of
fish being unable to swim
to keep up with the receding waters
and being left out on the land
the reason of course that the waters
receded so quickly is that this land
that was thrust up
is basically silt unconsolidated
sediment
and it wasn't going it wasn't long
before it was worn down
by the normal course of the river which
continued of course
so that's where the book takes its title
from
i would like to answer any questions you
may have
uh to the best of my ability there's a
microphone
set up on that side of the auditorium
and if you could make your way toward
that microphone
i would be very happy to field any of
your
inquiries
don't be shy now okay can you hear me i
sure can
okay i'm curious about uh the indian
tribe's ability to communicate
with each other to come to giving
speeches to various tribes
all the way from the northwest
territories down to the south how was he
able to
communicate effectively enough to you
know persuade them to join him
yes that's a good question and it's a
very simple answer
interpreters there were individuals
of one tribe or another who were
fluent in more than one language
he even had a translator
traveling with him so
the network among tribes was fairly
extensive
they all knew who each other were
and they traded and they fought and
so they had to have ways of
communicating i just wondered whether
there was a lingua
franca whether it was english french or
spanish
that they may have no it was it was
translators yeah right
you need to well the
no we need you to get to the mic because
uh
the the tv people really prefer that i
appreciate that
go ahead um yeah sure come on up
i apologize if you answered this earlier
but uh you said there were
major quakes in 900 and i believe 14
50. was that from uh indian accounts or
how did you get that no paleo
seismological studies
martisha tuttle and a a guy named eugene
schweig
from the u.s geological he's from the
u.s geological survey
in memphis tennessee i'm not sure where
martisha tuttle was based
but they went down to the region
uh around arkansas and dug up the land
that's what i mean when i talk about uh
the the uh the fellow who uh
who uh excavated in his backyard for me
with his backhoe you can see
the sand that was ejected right through
right through the silt you can see this
stream of sand
that's coming up that doesn't belong
there because it should be
way down below the surface and one more
question was the
did the earthquake occur during the
daylight hours or the nighttime hours
both the the first
the first major one occurred at 2 am
so you can imagine how terrifying that
must have been
and in fact many first-hand account
first-hand accounts say we thought it
was the end of the world
of course by daylight they realized it
was
an earthquake the second major event
happened during the daytime
and the third again happened in the
early morning hours
yeah please here in st louis the uh
story about the mississippi running
backwards has been part of the new
madrid story for a long time
in recent months after the tsunami
happened in southeast asia there have
been a series of presentations
by professors at washington university
from the earth sciences and
and geology departments and one of
some of these big researchers they
talked about you know why tsunamis
happen
and why earthquakes happen on plate
tectonics and all that stuff
and several people specifically asked
about the new madrid earthquake
and i specifically asked them the
question
did the mississippi river really run
backwards as we've always been told
and they said no that's a myth that is
impossible
that never happened and he explained all
the geological reasons why it never
happened so
i wanted to see what obviously it's the
title of your book so you must
believe that happened it's always been
the story that it happened but they're
now claiming
that that there's no real evidence that
that happens so what's your response to
that
well technically did the
mississippi run backwards no of course
not
but the effect of that huge block of
land
causing it to appear to the bystanders
if there's any doubt that that happened
just read the first-hand accounts i mean
they're in the book
but it's quite clear that people
who experienced those events believed
the river was running backwards and in
effect
it was was it really of course not
but if you were there i think the
technical difference between whether it
was really running backwards
or just seemed to be was a moot point
especially if you were caught in one of
those 30-foot
tsunami-like waves